Water was in short supply in England during
the summer of 1976.
Officials understood as early as September
1975 that water levels would be low the next
year thanks to 1975 being the fifth driest
year of the 20th century in the region.
While an average of 278 millimeters, or nearly
11 inches, of rain fell on England between
May and August from 1916 all the way through
1950, only 140 millimeters or about 5.5 inches
of rain fell during the same time period in
1976.
The months between April 1975 and August 1976
ultimately marked the driest period for the
region in recorded history, with data going
back well over two centuries.
If the dry weather wasn’t bad enough, abnormally
high temperatures made a bad problem even
worse.
Temperatures soared in the early summer, reaching
daily highs over 32 degrees Celsius, or nearly
90 degrees Fahrenheit for a record 15 consecutive
days from June 23rd to July 7th with the surrounding
weeks also being much hotter than normal.
For a country not only running short of water,
but also largely without air conditioning,
the whole thing was a sweaty mess.
Ladybirds, also known as ladybugs, flourished
in the dry conditions.
(See: The Fascinating Reason Ladybugs are
Called That) Martin Wainwright lived through
the drought in 1976 and described the immense
number of the insects:
No one had ever seen so many ladybirds – a
colleague remembers the sound they made when
you walked on them – crunch, crunch, crunch!
– and the absence of green on the ground
was made up for in the air by apocalyptic
swarms of aphids [ladybirds].
1976-2The English government used just about
every method available–leaflets, newspapers,
radio, television, and road signs— to encourage
limiting water use to only what was absolutely
necessary.
Most considered owning a dirty car during
this time to be downright patriotic.
People were encouraged to use no more than
five inches of water when taking a bath.
One television personality showered live on
television to show viewers how much water
could be saved with a quick shower as opposed
to a bath.
(Showering being fairly uncommon for people
at the time.)
But if a person decided to take a bath, the
government and national newspapers like the
Times and the Sun had helpful hints so as
not to waste the used water.
For instance, at one point the government
suggested “Save water, bath with a friend”,
which was soon a slogan that found its way
onto T-shirts, bumper stickers, and other
such product across the nation.
Newspapers encouraged readers to reuse old
bath water by using it to water plants in
their gardens or dumping it into toilets in
order to use it to flush with.
droughtWater became so scarce that water companies
could no longer supply tap water to certain
areas in Wales and England.
They instead installed standpipes, upright
and freestanding metal pipes with a tap, for
residents to get needed drinking water.
The use of hoses was also banned in some areas
with cars patrolling neighborhoods looking
for offenders, ready to hand out a steep fine
up to £400.
Officials’ big fear was the impact of the
drought on the economy.
Businesses in industries that used a significant
amount of water warned that forcing compliance
with water restrictions would lead to a decrease
in work for their employees and fear of a
three day work week.
While businesses certainly felt the squeeze
from the drought, such as seaweed processing
plant forced to lay off all of its 125 workers
when the nearby reservoir dried up, others
rose to the challenge.
Breweries across the country claimed to have
reduced their water use by between 14% and
25%.
One food production company reported cutting
down on their water use by 90% simply by changing
how they cleaned bottles.
Despite the water restrictions and the fears
of how they would hurt workers, English citizens
did not see much of a change in the unemployment
rate as a result of the extreme drought.
Water restrictions also applied to sporting
facilities, such as horse race tracks, golf
courses, and rugby fields.
Those locations that decided not to abide
by the rules and watered their grass anyway
faced repercussions from busybody neighbors.
For instance, women in Surrey took issue with
a local golf course and its groundskeepers
who decided to water the greens to keep them
abiding by their name, despite the restrictions.
They staged sit-ins at the course, even staying
overnight to make sure the sprinklers never
turned on, as well as harassed the club’s
employees.
Their methods worked, and the golf course
stopped watering its grass.
drough3Politicians passed legislation known
as the Drought Act in early August to help
curb water usage.
They also formed a Cabinet Drought Committee
to make recommendations on how best to get
the country through the ordeal.
Prime Minister Jim Callaghan even appointed
his sports minister, Denis Howell, to the
position of “Drought Supremo,” in charge
of coordinating water conservation efforts;
it was joked that Howell must have really
got on the wrong side of Callaghan to be given
such a position that was virtually guaranteed
to make sure nobody in the public liked him.
Beyond many suggestions, like putting a brick
in one’s toilet tank to reduce the water
used in a flush, Howell warned citizens the
water restrictions would be in place until
at least December.
But within days of the Drought Act being passed,
it rained during the August Bank Holiday.
At first just a trickle, ultimately the rainfall
began to ramp up into September and October,
with the following year being abnormally wet.
Howell soon became extremely unpopular due
to continuing to try to enforce restrictions
despite the heavy rainfall, sensibly wanting
to get the reservoir levels back to normal
before easing up on restrictions; for his
diligence to his duty, he was ultimately derisively
dubbed the ‘minister of the floods’.